[Applause]
has anyone in here really come close to
death almost die or actually what last
show I was at I asked some lady did die
you died
wait hold on hold on you can't just be
like yeah ah you can't you just said you
died
not you've had a cold and you're just
rolling right into it I gotta try to see
you it's very bright where are you
where raise your hand oh you look good
for almost dying okay
what happened or dying you died
five minutes did you see anything
so when you woke up you came back from
death
and you're like when are we going to
start this surgeon or like you just we
did the surgery and you died
do I have that right hold on you died
and they didn't be like by the way
I died for five minutes
I'll do that that's the
tummy tuck I died you know what I mean
like
it's like we got the cancer okay but
what good is that if I'm dead you know
what I mean we brought you back
so who told you you died
what do you have you have Blue Shield
bronze girl what do you have
they said to carry your pigeon to tell
you that you almost died
send the Raven let her know
let her know she died holy wait
also there's so many questions why is
your mom taking three weeks was she
walking do you
what happened
so your mom
took the advice of the doctors not to
tell you so you weren't under any more
stress she she took the advice of the
people who killed you
and that brought you back I was like
maybe you don't want to bring this up
maybe you don't want to talk to any
attorneys maybe just don't bring it you
just don't want to stress out the
community you know what I mean just a
lot of stress
you feel great how long ago did you die
is that not enough is that not did I
accurately ask that question
how long ago did you die
February of what
this year oh holy
God damn the Ghost of Christmas presents
here y'all hell yeah
hell yeah
God you really do look good for Diane a
couple months ago
this is why I gotta stop talking about
my ass lungs because you got
like it's real perspective you know I
mean like oh my luck she's like I died I
gotta died okay but how did your mom
tell you were you guys at lunch she'd be
like I got something to tell you and are
you like oh my God are you coming out of
the closet and she's like nah man we're
taking you out of the casket okay
yeah tell me we're gonna talk go ahead
what's your name
Ben what happened to you Ben okay Ben
just said he was born with his
intestines hanging out
and they
are my
huh you work for Blue Shield silver bro
he's up here it's all about his
intestine this doctor he
came and said oh
somebody else on that man I got a weak
stomach I got a weak stomach okay so
you're born with your intestines hanging
out and they figure you're a goner so
they baptize you so you don't go to hell
and live in
yeah that's what the Catholics and the
Christians like to do that nonsense
go ahead
I'm listen I'm an ordained minister here
I am
over one on well oh you don't want me to
want me to I don't have good numbers on
Weddings But Here you're good bro you're
good I bless you
okay so what happens how do you make it
today I
think you said I guess I pulled through
if you don't know
he threw well I'm glad you're here I'm
glad you made it
hey and you're down in the front row
give me some that's the hands blessed
now that hand's blessed
I saw I saw you did you not are you
care to share what's your name
Janine hi Janine what happened to you
a semi-cross shoe the center line hits
you head on how in the are you here
did you die
you died three times
that's what I'm talking about that lady
back there only died once she only died
once
Janine bricks headed she didn't say I'm
gonna go one more man you were sitting
on that three times you died on
the way to the hospital
holy tell us what happened what the
hell happened was he drunk was he text
him was he asleep
he was drinking and driving a big rig
across the center line how do you
remember do you know the information
like how fast he was going
you were in a coma for six and a half
weeks please tell me he worked for a
company like Peterbilt or Walmart or UPS
shout out to UPS Baltimore Avenue
uh FedEx please say he worked for a
corporation and not just some Regular
Joe out there hauling
thank you son speaking up she didn't
want to say that nothing
you all got Blue Shield silver for your
car insurance what the
no money
oh they thought you were the drunk
driver
Janine holy listen I'm not going to
ask any other questions
unless you have died four or more times
don't bother speaking up okay
Janine the Queen the death Queen down
Crown right there of death Janine I'm
out here killing them y'all the live and
Alive tour is live and alive I'm coming
to a city near you go get your tickets
at Ryan sickler.com
[Applause]